نتعامل دائما مع الغضب والحزن والاحباط
على انها احاسيس سلبيه يجب التخلص منها
على الفور لكن يجهل الكثيرون ان المشاعر
السلبيه لها فوائد ايجابيه فقد اكدت دراسه
كنديه ان الاشخاص عندما يصيبهم المزاج
السيء تنشط ذاكرتهم بشكل كبير جدا كما
ذكرت الدراسات ان المزاج السيء يعزز ايضا
ذاكره العين وذلك عن طريق تقليل المشتتات
كما ان المزاج السيء قد يؤدي الى تعزيز
الروح الابداعيه لدى الاشخاص وهذا ما اكده
ايضا علم الاعصاب ان هناك رابطه بين
الابداع والمشاعر المزاجيه السيئه واكد
الباحثون ان الاشخاص الذين يتعرضون لمشاعر
الحزن او الغضب او البكاء تكون لديهم
سلوكيات جيده ومهذبه في التعامل مع
الاخرين ويطلبون ما يريدونه بطريقه هادئه
كما اظهر التجارب الاجتماعيه ان المزاج
السيء يؤدي الى زياده الدافع لدى الاشخاص
ورغبتهم في العمل بشكل اكثر جديه فهم
يبذلون جهدا اكبر من اجل انجاز المهام على
كل حال